[Musique]
nato jonathan comme un conte l'histoire
elle est incroyable ok mais après je
raconte mon histoire c'est celle de
piano et franchement c'est un truc de
dingue d'accord dans mon histoire vous
désire déjeuner c'est gentil merci
monsieur dans une zone et on a une
choucroute de la mer sur son lit pour
simple après fikin peux me mettais en 6
merci au revoir donc dans mon histoire
je un atom secondes c'est peut-être
important
les garçons de koné garcia je suis
tellement fan donc dans mon histoire
en fait ça va encore nous donne raconte
une histoire de ouf apparemment oui et
on m a commencé donc si tu peux moi
pareil hier j'ai vu julie gayet la voile
c'est une amie aime raconter une
anecdote mon poste j'ai pas dormi de la
nuit
oui mais il arrive on t'appelle on
t'appellera quelqu'un m'appelle il
arrivait juste là il arrive aux
agricultures je parte avec tes signal
mais postule pas du tout tu peux rester
donc je te disais dans mon histoire
bon j'ai vite je dois retrouver cyprien
c'est une urgence si ludovic tu as une
minute et j'écoute ton histoire mais il
faut que tu sois court et concis
donc
excusez moi il est midi comme chaque
jour à la même heure nous allons
observer une minute de silence en la
mémoire de johnny hallyday nous manque
tellement soir
[Musique]
deux chèques de bout en bout du quai
l'abandon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
wu
stéphane pâques
[Musique]
ces rues
et ce match
[Musique]
procès à la haye
non
[Musique]
bonjour et
vous reconnaître d'arrêt
m
oui
[Musique]
boucles et lille quelle île manhattan
selma tremble deux tireurs qui ont de
l'entraînement car ce n'est pas enfin
qui brandit les pays il fait s'abattre
la colère de dieu sur celui qui fait le
mal je vais les retrouver
si on doit passer ce type dans les trois
ou quatre heures ils disparaîtront et
quand vous faire 21 ton permettent de
sortir de ligne bouclé lille
quelle île manhattan
ils m'ont dit que tu exécutes les tueurs
de flics magnifique on se coltine un
malade de la gâchette mais bien de faire
attention en disant à malades de la
gâchette
c'était un piège appelle ça quand tu que
je vienne
si tu prends ce chemin pourra regarder
par-dessus ton et pour le tout temps
je préfère regarder le diable en face et
tu est celui qui exécute les tueurs de
flics
je vais retrouver
combien de policiers 8 le pire carnage
juin 18 ans ils avaient été appelés pour
un cambriolage
si j'ai choisi c'est pas pour rien je
vais les retrouver
si on choque pas ces types dans les
trois ou quatre heures ils disparaîtront
le conte est offert il y à 21 points qui
permettent de sortir de manhattan
on monte des barrages
on arrête tous les trains ont toutes les
stations de métro
ensuite on inonde l'île de flics ça pas
de sens le 17 et 30 kg et on se retrouve
avec trois temps il se passe quoi je
veux la vérité c'est tout
ils ont juste été une tête brûlée celui
qui exécute les tueurs de fric
deskom le coup
moi
patiner ses com comment respirer je peux
pas m'imaginer vicent et si je
m'arrêtais ça serait comme noyé d'un
coup tu as métaphore est devenu hyper
d'art tu es une très belle patine us
merci mais j'arrête
j'arrête le patinage je pense que tu as
juste un tout petit peu peur j'ai pas un
petit peu peur je suis terrifiée tu
était parfaite
aujourd'hui quand je te regarde je ne
vois que du potentiel gazier je m'éclate
le genou à la batte de base-ball ou ça
ferait trop tonia
[Musique]
j'ai vu des vidéos de tes anciennes
performance tu avais peur de rien qu'à
regarder des vidéos de moi je pense
faire de porno ma mère mon croient
incapable je veux lui prouver le
contraire mon devoir de la romance de la
tragédie on le voit du sexe moi ça me va
et toi j'ai l'habitude de patiner seul
il me faut du temps pour m'ajuster
et là c'est sûr je n'y touche si tu
laisses tomber 4 tu regretteras d'avoir
survécu
honnêtement toi et moi on peut carrément
viser les jeux olympiques
on va pas se mettre la pression
tu seras jamais une championne jamais
t'es sûr que tout va bien
je sens que mon monde s'écroulait
tout le monde peut ouvrir un nouveau
chapitre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout ce que vous avez à faire c'est de
m'inviter en retrait
[Musique]
à 19 heures de classe
où
s'amuse pascal shylock ce chiffre mais
[Musique]
chut chut
et dans une longue robe chic
[Musique]